[Narrator:] This is the virus, a tiny organism
less than one millionth of an inch in diameter,
magnified here thousands of times by the electron
microscope.
This, the disease caused by the virus.
One which has plagued man since recorded history.
This, the scientist, Dr. John Enders of Harvard,
whose work made possible an effective vaccine
which can prevent the disease.
This, the place where the vaccine is tested
and produced
for use throughout the world. West Point,
Pennsylvania.
And this, the vaccine itself,
the end product of medicine's long match with
measles.
[Music]
[Narrator:] Many parents think of measles
as just a common nuisance,
which makes their children feel miserable
and keeps them out of school for a while.
But physicians today know that measles is
more than a nuisance.
It can bring on bacterial infections,
can cause fatal pneumonia, and in some cases
encephalitis,
inflammation of the brain.
Each case needs good medical care.
It is not so much because of the usual rash
and fever symptoms of measles
that the doctor says he'll check back in a
day or so,
but rather to be sure the young patient is
not developing serious complications.
Electroencephalograms indicate that half the
patients with natural measles
show some brain involvement during the disease.
After the disease has passed, most patients,
such as this boy being tested in Philadelphia's
Children's Hospital,
show a return to a normal brain wave pattern,
a distinct contrast to the abnormal pattern
recorded during the disease.
Still, in those patients who showed the abnormal
encephalogram during their illness,
the possibility of future emotional instability,
or mental deficiency, or even mental retardation,
cannot be ruled out.
Fortunately, only about one measles patient
in a thousand develops encephalitis.
As of this time, measles is by far our most
serious epidemic childhood disease.
Although nearly half a million cases are reported
each year,
the actual number is probably closer to four
million.
In 1961, after the polio vaccines had reduced
the deaths from that disease to 90,
that same year, 434 measles deaths were reported.
In the less developed countries of the world,
the toll taken by measles is much greater.
In Nigeria it is estimated that one out of
four babies contracting measles dies from it.
The tragic toll of measles is also told in
a neighboring republic, Upper Volta,
where in one village an epidemic killed 113
out of 115 children who got the disease.
Across the ocean in Chile,
measles accounts for half of all childhood
deaths from acute communicable diseases each year.
Thus now, as it has for centuries past,
measles takes its toll of human life.
It was a Persian physician named Rhazes
who gave the first classical description of
measles ten centuries ago.
He and other Arabian physicians first suggested
that measles
is a distinct and separate disease.
It had often been considered a form of the
pox.
But these early doctors described and treated
the symptoms of the disease, not the cause.
There were many remedies but no prevention.
The cause remained a mystery.
Then, in the eighteenth century,
the light began to dawn on some of the causes
of infectious disease.
Jenner of England, Pasteur of France, Koch
of Germany, founded the science of bacteriology.
With improved microscopes came the microbe
hunters.
They identified bacteria, grew them,
and experimented with them in their laboratories.
Their search pointed the way to discovery
of another disease agent,
a millimicrobe, the virus,
and to the development of a new medical research
specialty, virology.
At hospitals and research centers today,
virology is a major and growing scientific
discipline.
And in a laboratory attached to Children's
Hospital in Boston,
is one of the nation's most respected virologists,
Harvard scientist and Nobel Prize winner Dr. John Enders.
In 1953, a few years after Dr. Enders' work
paved the way for the polio vaccines,
he and his team turned their attention to
measles.
The first objective: to find and to grow the
measles virus.
Blood samples taken by Dr. Thomas Peebles
from children with natural measles
were injected into cultures of human kidney
cells and incubated.
With techniques like these being carried out
today by Dr. Samuel Katz,
tissue cultures brought from the incubator
are checked for any changes in the cells.
Obtaining even one successful growth of pure
virulent measles virus
is one of the most difficult laboratory achievements.
Finally, in 1954, one culture obtained from
an 11-year old measles patient
named David Edmonston begins to show remarkable changes in cell structure.
These might be caused by the measles virus.
Dr. Enders is called in to observe it.
To prove that it is the measles virus, they
decide to inject it,
as Dr. Katz demonstrates here,
into the only animal that will contract the
disease--monkeys.
Monkeys which have never been exposed to measles.
In a few days, when the monkey develops measles,
they know they have isolated and grown the
Edmonston strain of the measles virus.
Now they discuss the longest, and in many
ways the most difficult,
task of all, how to attenuate or weaken the virus
so that it will produce antibodies and thus
provide immunity
without transmitting the disease itself.
It's a little like walking on a tightrope.
The virus is grown first in one tissue culture,
then in another.
Human kidney tissues, human amnion, egg amnion,
chick embryo.
It is transferred.
It is incubated.
Always carefully watched and safeguarded against
bacterial infection at every stage.
As the weeks pass, the virus makes 72 passages in all,
before Dr. Enders decides it's ready for the
next tests
with experimental animals.
Two groups of monkeys are used.
One group is given the attenuated virus as
a vaccine.
The other group is not vaccinated.
Later, both groups are given the full-strength
measles virus.
In a few weeks the results are evident.
The monkeys that were not vaccinated developed
measles.
The ones like this one that were given the
experimental vaccine show no signs of measles,
but they have developed protective antibodies.
Dr. Enders and Dr. Katz now know that they
have developed for the first time
a vaccine which will provide safe protection
against measles.
It only remains to test the attenuated live
virus vaccine with humans.
Starting first with children at a state school,
Dr. Katz then inoculates volunteers who come
to his lab at the hospital.
The results are most encouraging
and spark interest throughout the world of
virology.
One who saw the importance of moving forward
with this breakthrough
was Dr. Maurice Hilleman, Director of Virus
and Cell Biology
at the Merck Sharp and Dohme Research Laboratories
in West Point, Pennsylvania.
With cultures of attenuated virus from Dr.
Enders' lab,
Dr. Hilleman, Dr. Eugene Buynak, and colleagues
undertake development of larger experimental
quantities.
At the same time, Dr. Hilleman draws up the design
of the next critical step--broadscale clinical testing.
Collaborating with Dr. Hilleman is a group
at Children's Hospital, Philadelphia,
headed by Dr. Joseph Stokes, nationally known
pediatrician and medical scientist.
Here with him, Doctors Robert E. Weibel, J.
Ronald Halenda, and Charles M. Riley
map out a plan for field trials in southeastern
Pennsylvania.
More than fifteen hundred children and their
parents cooperate.
One group of children receives the live vaccine
by injection.
The trial also studies how gamma globulin,
given in the other arm,
modifies reactions to the vaccine.
Another set of children, for comparison, receives injections
that do not contain the live vaccine.
A blood sample taken from each child before
vaccination
tells which children have not previously had
the disease.
These samples are analyzed in the research laboratory.
Another sample taken four weeks later
shows whether the child has developed antibodies
to the vaccine.
Then, over the next year or so, a close check is kept
to see if any of the children contract the
real disease.
The results fulfill all expectations.
The vaccinated children are protected.
None of them get measles when exposed to it.
From New York University, Dr. Saul Krugman
reports similar findings,
as does Dr. Fred McCrumb at the University
of Maryland.
The trials spread across the country.
The vaccine is tested in 18 states from the
eastern seaboard to California.
As the data from all these field trials accumulate,
answers to earlier questions emerge.
The live measles vaccine is producing a high
level of immunity,
safely, consistently, and the immunity appears
to be long-lasting.
Answers are also emerging on the problems
of large-scale production and quality control,
as manufacture gets underway in the biological
laboratories at West Point, Pennsylvania.
The less-developed countries in Africa watch
this progress with great interest.
Helping them launch studies of the vaccine
are first, the U.S. Armed Forces Epidemiological Board,
and later the World Health Organization and U.S Public Health Service.
It was to the National Institutes of Health
in 1962
that an urgent request came from one of these
African nations.
Upper Volta, satisfied with preliminary testing,
asks for a massive vaccination effort.
"Help us protect our children before measles
strikes again."
Begun in time, it could save thousands of
lives.
The response is immediate.
To help train local teams and study the immunization
of this population,
the Public Health Service sends a medical
team from its Division of Biologic Standards.
Vehicles are supplied by the Agency for International Development.
The vaccine is contributed by Merck Sharp and Dohme.
The drum speaks to the people.
"Come to the village, the doctors are here
with the medicine.
It can protect your children."
And the people do come, bringing their children,
bringing their hopes and fears.
At each village, the jet inoculator used is
carefully explained.
Then begins the long hard job of giving the
lifesaving vaccine to the children.
As soon as one village has been protected,
the team must move onto the next.
Everywhere, they are greeted by huge crowds.
The vaccine must be kept refrigerated to protect
it from the intense African heat.
At each new location the inoculator is cleaned
and checked.
The lines seem endless.
But all the children must get the vaccine.
Village after village, the people come by
the thousands.
The team works around the clock.
At last the work is done.
By March 1963, 700,000 children in Upper Volta
receive live-virus measles vaccine.
Many thousands of lives may have been saved.
That same month, the Department of Health,
Education, and Welfare
licenses the vaccine for general use in the
United States.
The Surgeon General of the United States Public Health Service, Dr. Luther Terry,
has this to say.
[Dr. Terry:] Over the past several years,
measles vaccines have been successfully tested
both in this country and abroad.
This painstaking evaluation was made possible
by the cooperative effort of scientists,
both in and out of government, by physicians,
by the drug industry,
and by thousands of unselfish and courageous
parents
who have permitted their children to participate
in the field trials.
The Secretary of Health, Education, and Welfare
has now licensed the vaccines for general use.
As increasing numbers of children are vaccinated, we will be well on the way
to eradicating a disease that down through
the centuries
has killed millions of children and left others impaired mentally and physically.
All of those who have contributed in any way to this cause for better health
can be proud of a great achievement.
[Narrator:] Within 48 hours of official government
licensing,
supplies of the vaccine are ready for shipment
to doctors throughout the country.
Today, production of the vaccine is in full
swing, protected at each step
by the elaborate manufacturing controls established
by industry, together with the federal government.
Production of the live virus vaccine begins
with fertile chicken eggs.
To assure absolute purity, the eggs are taken from select, disease-free chickens
kept in strict sanitary isolation.
The eggs are opened and the embryos are carefully
removed.
They are minced and washed, then further broken down by a chemical substance
that reduces the tissue to individual cells.
It is only in living cells that the virus can grow.
To keep these cells alive and growing, a special
nutrient is prepared.
A precise number of cells is counted and introduced
into each bottle.
Then the measles virus is introduced.
Eighty percent of the culture bottles are
infected.
The other 20 percent are used as controls.
They provide a way to check against any possible
impurities in the cells.
The cells attach themselves to the walls,
and in the infected bottles the virus grows
in the cells.
Now begins a three-week period in which the
nutrient is periodically replaced.
The cells are rinsed and the growth is carefully
watched.
The fluid now taken from the culture bottles
contains a high concentration of measles virus.
The individual harvests are pooled together.
Also, a stabilizer is added and samples are
removed for testing.
Finally, the entire pool of vaccine is filtered.
This, at last, is the pure live virus vaccine.
It is frozen at minus 75 degrees to await
results of final testing.
It takes 137 days to produce the vaccine.
Ninety-six of these are devoted to meticulous
quality control testing.
More than 35 separate tests are performed
to ensure
potency, safety, and other measures of quality
control.
For each person involved in the actual production
of the vaccine,
eight people devote their time to testing
and control.
Finally, the vaccine which has passed all
of the tests
is thawed and transferred to individual bottles.
These are then freeze-dried, capped, and sealed.
The end result is a single-dose vial of the
live, attenuated-virus measles vaccine.
But the real story of a vaccine is told in
the fears and smiles of a little girl
who today is given greater protection than
ever before
against the infectious diseases of childhood.
There remain other viruses to be isolated,
other vaccines to come,
but they will.
And like this little girl,
millions of children over the world will have
an even safer and healthier life.
[Music]